bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 l'aktu du vendredi 28 mars et on
commence tout de suite avec l'image du
jour hier le président françois hollande
recevez au château de versailles son
homologue chinois xi jinping
après une visite du lieu un dîner
préparé par le chef alain ducasse était
organisé au grand trianon pour rappel
cette année nous fêtons le 50e
anniversaire des relations diplomatiques
entre la france et la chine une
exposition est organisée au château de
versailles pour l'occasion un château
qui a déjà reçu bien des grands de ce
monde parmi lesquels le couple kennedy
ou encore la reine d'angleterre
elizabeth ii
dans l'actualité d'hier toujours une
situation de crise chez chrysalis cette
ong dont le siège est situé au domaine
du bus loyer à magny les hameaux ne
serez pas en mesure de payer la
soixantaine de salariés en insertion à
la fin du mois de mars une réunion de
crise était organisée ce jeudi
après-midi en difficulté financière
depuis 2012 la direction a déjà alerté
les pouvoirs publics mais en vain
chrysalis attend des subventions de
l'épars de la part de l'état et de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'heure l'association
d'insertion n'a pas obtenu d'écho
favorable la période électorale et
l'incertitude des scrutins rendant les
discussions plus complexes
environnement maintenant et cette crèche
de versailles qui a reçu dernièrement un
label bio nourriture biologique
économies d'énergie chasse au gaspillage
tout est pensé de manière verte même les
jouets des enfants sabrina signer
ici adultes et enfants voit la vie en
vert
depuis quatre ans protéger la planète
est devenue une devise pour cette
structure qui accueille chaque jour près
de 60 enfants un travail d équipe dont
la direction n'est pas peu fier on a
décidé de travailler sur l'économie
d'énergie
l'économie d'eau
l'alimentation pour proposer du bio le
plus possible respecter la saisonnalité
des pour les enfants tous nos travaux
donc on utilise des produits écologiques
on travaille sur le bâtiment pour
améliorer aussi la dépense énergétique
voilà plein de choses sur la vie
quotidienne en fait depuis 2009 la
crèche a réduit sa consommation
d'électricité de 31% et sa consommation
d'eau de 40 % mais les efforts se font
aussi du côté des activités proposées
aux enfants ici par exemple les petits
jouent avec de la pâte à modeler fait
maison
on essaie aussi de d'acheter uniquement
des jeux qui ont sont offerts matériaux
recyclés et recyclables et également
cette structure que vous voyez là donc
c'est une structure qui est faite par
une entreprise qui est vraiment
spécialisés qui fait uniquement des
produits avec du bois qui voit là en
gestion durable en utilisant du vernis
de la colle qui n'a aucun impact pour la
santé ce travail en faveur de l'écologie
n'est pas passée inaperçue en 2010 la
structure a obtenu le label de
l'association écolo crèche un sésame que
la direction entend conserver en
poursuivant ses efforts parallèlement un
projet de covoiturage pour le personnel
est actuellement à l'étude
ils sont trop mignons on reste sur le
thème de l'environnement puisque je
reçois aujourd'hui des militants
greenpeace de paris et versailles à mes
côtés aurélia 2000 bonjour leeroy
malakal un bon jour et philippe
d'orléans bonjour philippe ce vendredi
28 mars dès 19 heures à la maison de
quartier de porchefontaine vous
organisez une soirée publique de
présentation de votre organisation une
organisation que nous allons également
présentés sur ce plateau alors on va
commencer philippe par le commencement
comment est née déjà l'organisation
greenpeace est née de la contestation de
la part de jeunes américains et
canadiens
concernant les les essais nucléaires en
alaska en 1971 ils se sont rendus sur la
place sur le lieu des explosions pour
empêcher ces et c'est précisément en
plein air et c'est comme ça de ses
actions directes non violentes que
greenpeace est né alors depuis 71 on
rappelle maintenant que greenpeace est
présent dans 27 pays aujourd'hui c'est 3
millions d'adhérents à travers le monde
pour cette organisation non
gouvernementale aujourd'hui comment
fonctionne cette organisation philippe
c'est une organisation que vous venez de
le dire internationale c'est à dire que
c'est l'ensemble des pays qui qui font
greenpeace international
c'est au niveau de greenpeace
international qu on se met d'accord
qu'on planifie les différentes campagnes
et qui sont relayés après au niveau de
chaque pays comme vous l'avez dit 27
pays et à l'intérieur d'un pays comme la
france par exemple il vient nous
déclinons les campagnes qui sont décidés
au niveau mondial de façon à informer le
public et proposer des solutions et en
france greenpeace et 25 groupes locaux
c'est plus de 160 mille adhérents
70 salariés et des groupes comme le
nôtre sont là pour précisément essayé
d'informer le public et proposer des
solutions alors justement fils dorian
quelles valeurs défend défendre ces
groupes que vous citez
greenpeace est avant tout un
un mouvement qui qui essaie de lancer
des alertes donc concernant les risques
environnementaux et
concernant la paix c'est le coeur de 5
de son activité
et ses valeurs sont avant tout
l'engagement la non-violence et et
l'information auprès du grand public
comment ça se traduit sur le terrain
j'avais tourné vers vers leeroy malakal
les royaux sait comment ça se traduit
sur le sur le terrain comment
l'organisation ajoute l aujourd'hui
tout qu'on identifie un problème donc au
niveau mondial d'abord on va essayer de
bien s'informer sur pour avoir pour
avoir débit comprendre les enjeux et
aussi ici de trouver des solutions et
puis rentrer en contact avec les acteurs
les responsables de ces problèmes là et
malheureusement quand le quand le
dialogue se révèlent infructueuses bah
on passe à l'information du public et
c'est là que des groupes des groupes
locaux comme comme le nôtre à versailles
sont utiles pour essayer d'aller voir
les gens les informer parfois leur faire
signer des pétitions pour faire monter
le point et obliger les responsables à
se prononcer à agir et puis enfin
parfois des actions quand il s'agit
vraiment de mettre la chose sur la place
publique et la sphère relayé de manière
importante par les médias alors là tous
en tête des opérations à mener par par
greenpeace des opérations des opérations
très médiatique qu'elles soient les
principales victoire qu'a remporté
l'organisation
historiquement bas c'est la toute
première campagne celle sur les essais
nucléaires kkk fonctionner vu que
l'essai nucléaire le bout de quelques
années ont été arrêtés du moins dans
l'atmosphère et puis par la suite on a
eu il y en a eu beaucoup d'autres sur le
nucléaire l'enfouissement des déchets en
mer mais aussi sur toutes nos campagnes
sur la déforestation assez récemment il
ya un principal exportateur qui a qui
s'est engagé à arrêter la déforestation
pour l'huile de palme sur les vêtements
les produits toxiques dans les vêtements
il ya beaucoup de marques qui depuis
quelques années se sont engagés à
arrêter deux introduire des produits
toxiques dans leur production
mais aussi des océans la pêche la pêche
à chaque ancien vert des pêches
intensives voilà en europe on commença
plutôt aider la petite pêche la pêche
durable et puis sur l'agriculture aussi
greenpeace essaye de promouvoir une
agriculture durable et des amas
notamment via via les amap mais qui sont
des mais justement des
solutions locales et nous on essaie de
faire en sorte que les gouvernements
mettent en place des politiques pour
aider les agriculture durable et puis
aussi il informe les consommateurs pour
qu'ils soient aussi eu dans une démarche
plus plus durable et j'ai pour ça qu'on
a créé un le guide le guetteur alors ça
on va en parler tout à l'heure du guide
le guetteur je me tourne vers vous
maintenant aurélia 2000 aurélia cette
soirée de présentation là toute la
petite présentation convient de faire on
l'a fait en résumé mais j'imagine que
c'est ça que les gens vont retrouver ce
soir à la maison de quartier de
porchefontaine à 19 heures voilà tout à
fait donc en fait on est là ce soir pour
faire connaître l'association donc faire
éventuellement à connaître nos campagnes
comme vous nous présentez philip ely
reuil et aussi donc nous faire connaître
auprès des associations puisque pour le
moment
on n'a pas encore identifié les
problématiques locales mais justement
tient vraiment à travailler auprès des
associations de tout bassin aux
parisiens pour justement aider les
citoyens des consommateurs
est de sensibiliser auprès des campagnes
de greenpeace france et donc voilà donc
nous serons à ce soir pour répondre aux
questions du public et éventuellement
proposer aux gens de nous rejoindre en
tant que membre oui c'est ça c'est aussi
l'occasion pour vous de recruter de
nouveaux bénévoles voilà tout à fait
nous verrons voilà puisque mon arrivée
en janvier donc nous sommes quelques
militants actuellement mon a vraiment
besoin de tout le monde effectivement
pour sensibiliser les problématiques et
les campagnes dans l'est dans les
yvelines comment ça va se traduire
quelle campagne vous allez mettre en
place
aurélia si vous voulez en parler ou les
royaux philippe alors tout d'abord celle
là dernière sur laquelle on travaille
c'est l'agriculture donc écologique ou
en fait justement on tient vraiment un
privilège et une production locale et
surtout donc sans pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles notamment et tueurs de
pollinisateurs puisqu'on a un très gros
déclin d'abeilles sachant qu'
aujourd'hui si nous n'avons plus
d'abeilles c'est 75% de tout ce que nous
voyons sur les étalages sur nos marchés
que nous n'aurons plus donc c'est
vraiment très grave et également sur les
ogm
puisque voilà aujourd'hui donc comme
vous l'expliqué leeroy on essaye de
faire passer des choses auprès des
gouvernements pour ne pas que l'on
retrouve des ogm dans nos assiettes
n'importe comment donc voilà alors effet
car justement le froid qu'il ya une
ligne qui a été mis en place
dernièrement ça c'est un nouveau projet
qu'on voit qu'on voit à l'image qui
s'appelle le guetteur alors expliquez
nous un peu le principe du guetteur
leeroy
guetteurs ça a été une enquête auprès
des marques de trop de 150 marques qui
ont été interrogés pour savoir s'ils
utilisaient des pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles ou des ogm la plupart des
marques ont joué le jeu et ont répondu
soit qu'elles ont utilisé soit qu'elle
était en face de ne plus en utiliser
malheureusement toutes les marques n'ont
pas répondu donc on a souhaité les
mettre celle aussi qui n'ont pas répondu
à notre questionnaire et puis ça permet
aux prêts aux consommateurs produit par
produit marque par marque de savoir plus
tôt vers quelles marques sont orientées
comme on souhaite ne pas consommer de
dodo gm ou ne pas aider les
développements des pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles alors comment fait on pour
devenir un guetteur de greenpeace
bah il suffit d'aller sur le site de
greenpeace mme que greenpeace point fr
puis là on voit parler du guetteur et
puis on peut comme ça sur internet se
renseigner tout comme cuche sur le
papier quels sont les produits qui sont
qui sont nocifs et puis on peut
s'inscrire en tant que guetteur pour
être tenu informé du sud du sud de la
campagne et puis pour apporter son
soutien justement à cette démarche s'il
dort hier je me tourne vers vous comment
fait-on tout simplement pour devenir
adhérent de greenpeace aujourd'hui
c'est très facile pour devenir adhérent
de greenpeace il suffit de le demander
et
niveau financier
les adhésions vont de 1 euro à ce qu'on
peut donner donc ça n'est pas un
problème
financier particulier c'est surtout un
engagement qu'on demande aux gens de se
dire voilà est-ce que vous soutenez nos
démarches est ce que vous voulez être
adhérent et puis après les gens donnent
ce qu'ils veulent mais c'est marginal
par rapport à aux symboles de l'adhésion
symbole de l'adhésion c'est surtout nous
supportons vos actions et nous sommes
éventuellement prêt à vous rejoindre
merci pour toutes ces explications cette
présentation de ce guetteur et on
rappelle ce soir ce vendredi 28 mars à
versailles à la maison de quartier de
porchefontaine cette réunion publique de
présentation de votre organisation non
gouvernementale il faut bien le préciser
greenpeace et on continue d'ailleurs sur
un sujet environnement dans ce journal
est ce que vous avez eu vent de ces hlm
en bois construit à saint cyr l'école
est ce que ça vous dit quelque chose pas
encore
alors ce sont des logements sociaux
économiques et écologiques je le disais
c'est à saint cyr l'école la réalisation
quasiment achevé représente un
investissement de plusieurs millions
d'euros sabrina sit in et
un chantier en apparence comme les
autres ou presque car dans ces
constructions d'achèvement cours à saint
cyr l'école on pense avant tout
développement durable ici la structure
des immeubles est réalisée en bois le
bois déjà d'un coefficient d'isolation
qui est plus importante que le veto
dès qu'on vous toucher du bois et c'est
beau il fait pas froid vous touchez du
béton c'est froid ce sont des bâtiments
qui sont très très bien désolé pour
travailler dans le sens de l'économie
des énergies
et aussi utiliser une énergie qui
renouvelable le bois ont fait pousser
des arbres on les coupe on construit
avec encore fait pousser un autre arbre
le béton on vous retire toujours dans
les énergies fossiles il ya une brune
elle tient sa connaissance du bois d'un
long séjour en scandinavie pour lui la
construction de ce type d'habitation
collective et appelé à se développer
dans l'hexagone selon lui le bois permet
une économie d'énergie d'environ 20% par
rapport au béton le bailleur lui a en
tout cas été sensible à ce procédé on
entrer dans une démarche de
développement durable dans les années
2000 et donc on cherche avant tout à
faire des économies d'énergie des
économies de ressources et limiter les
consommations les les productions de gaz
à effet de serre donc le bois est un
matériau qui n'y répond à toutes ces
problématiques c'est le seul matériau de
construction qui est durable et qui
naturel autre démarche en faveur de
l'écologie l'installation de panneaux
solaires qui permettra aux familles de
réaliser des économies 60 % de l'eau
chaude sera autofinancé grâce au solaire
thermique
les occupants devront financer que les
40% restant un gain non négligeable pour
les futurs locataires qui devraient
emménager d'ici trois mois
pour beaucoup de familles partir en
vacances ce reste un luxe le secours
populaire organise des séjours et des
sorties pour ceux qui n'ont pas
l'opportunité de partir l'été
l'association cherche aussi des
bénévoles pour accompagner les enfants
pendant cette période sabrina sit in et
le château de versailles ne reçoit pas
que des visiteurs c'est ici que la
fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire a présenté son programme 2014
de sa campagne vacances et loisirs
l'association permet chaque année aux
enfants défavorisés de sortir de leur
quotidien et de partir en vacances en
france un enfant sur trois n'a pas cette
opportunité là quand même à kantigui sur
ce coup là depuis 1945
de l'après guerre où en fait on a lancé
la campagne avec l'accueil d'enfants
victimes de la guerre
pour donc l'accueil d'enfants dans des
familles bénévoles après la guerre est
donc là cette année on commence la
campagne là où une marche pour que les
enfants puissent partir et on vacances
pendant l'été et ainsi que leurs
familles et donc l'an dernier au dernier
un chiffre qu'on arrive à thiers 90
enfants en vacances et une vingtaine de
familles cet été la journée des oubliés
des vacances se déroulera le 20 août à
ouistreham en normandie avec l'aide des
bénévoles et des accompagnateurs le
secours populaire propose à ces familles
d'envoyer leurs enfants dans des
colonies ou dans des familles d'accueil
tous les enfants qui partent sont ravis
ils veulent tous repartir au début ils
sont un peu angoissés les parents sont
angoissés donc on est obligé un petit
peu de les rassurer parce que c'est des
enfants qui vivent dans des milieux
défavorisés et qui vont quitter pour la
première fois leurs parents qui vont
partir pour la première fois en vacances
et à partir de 5 ans donc il faut
absolument rassurer les familles le
château de versailles partenaires
bénévoles n'a pas hésité à soutenir la
campagne un grand établissement comme
versailles doit s'ouvrir à tous les
publics et à toutes les natures le
public et nous nous efforçons d'établir
temps en mode de médiation spécifique
que dans une volonté d'accessibilité la
plus générale possible et sans exclusion
avec un souci d'accueil généralistes
c'est à dire que tous les publics soient
reçues ensemble et dans les mêmes lieux
simultanément pour la campagne 2014 le
secours populaire recherche des familles
bénévoles pour accueillir des enfants
pendant leurs vacances l'association a
également besoin de dons financiers pour
organiser ces séjours
c'est un événement qui a toujours autant
de succès cette année l'hôpital des
nounours ah qu'ils plus de 300 enfants
des écoles de versailles et de vélizy
accompagnés de leurs doudous malade il
parcourt les services de l'hôpital tenu
par les étudiants en médecine de l'ue de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines yolaine thorez et jonathan
willeman
dont la selle d'attentes les enfants
s'occupent et patiente jusqu'à leur tour
ils sont venus faire soigner leur
nounours il y en a car ici
et au stick est venu piquer le bien de
tous qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour
payer la gastro parce que là deux
caravanes et des carrières
à versailles dans cet hôpital fictif une
centaine d'étudiants en médecine de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines se transforme en
nounoursologues il ausculte et oriente
les enfants vers différents services en
fonction de la pathologie de leurs
peluches un événement organisé depuis
plusieurs années par l'association
poèmes les enfants ont eu assez peur
d'acheter médecin parce que généralement
c'est des moments où ils sont fatigués
malades ils sont pas bien du coup ils
peuvent avoir un mauvais a priori du
médecin et le but c'est vraiment de
casser cette image négative de la blouse
blanche et du médecin et de rassurer
l'enfant vis-à-vis des soins de
l'hôpital on va décaler figure avec mon
petit d'études qui valent endormi
après le stand de consultation les
enfants emmènent leur nounours au poste
de soins au bloc opératoire
chez le dentiste ou encore ici chez les
radiologues on leur montre que la
radiologie ça fait une image de
l'intérieur de leurs nounours et on
essaye de leur montrer que ça en fait ça
fait pas mal c'est juste une photo et
que ça prend un peu de temps et que même
s'ils sont tous seuls faut pas
s'inquiéter organisé sur une semaine à
versailles puis à vélizy l'hôpital des
nounours a accueilli cette année plus de
300 enfants
économie maintenant et le centre
commercial bel air de rambouillet qui
innovent désormais vous pouvez payer
dans certains magasins du centre avec
votre téléphone présentation de ce
nouveau concept avec roma gras bête et
patrick jacques de dixmude
d'accord elle installe aujourd'hui keeps
ce mode de paiement ne vous dit
peut-être rien c'est une application
mobile qui permet au client de payer
directement avec leur smartphone ce mode
de paiement est disponible au centre
commercial bel air de rambouillet
confirmation vous vous inscrivez ans
après l'avoir téléchargée vous activez
votre carte bancaire dans le cadre d'un
processus qui est sécurisé qui a été
revu par les instances compétentes en la
matière et une fois que vous utilisez
en fait vous approchez votre téléphone
de l'équipement du commerçant et ont
déclenché la transaction de paiement au
travers d'un son n'utilise en fait une
technologie partant haut parleurs et du
micro du téléphone le centre commercial
bel air est le premier d'île de france à
s'équiper de ce système équipe ce ne se
contente pas seulement du paiement par
mobile l'application récompense ses
utilisateurs via plusieurs remises et
promotion dans les différents commerces
partenaires d'ailleurs près de la moitié
des commerçants du centre n'ont pas
hésité à s'acquitter des 10 euros de
cotisation mensuelle pour le terminal
nous cherchons un outil de mutualisation
de partage des promotions et de et de
cohésion de l'ensemble des des
commerçants du centre commercial pour
répondre à des besoins qui sont les
besoins de clientèle de fidélisation de
promotion
d'augmentation du chaland du flux et ai
pu continuer à être compétitif sur un
marché qu'il est de plus en plus
concurrentiel au cours de l'année une
dizaine de centres en france adopteront
cette technologie avec l'ambition que
les clients délaissent leur portefeuille
sport maintenant lancée par la ligue
féminine de basket en 2005 l'opération
marraine de coeur permet de faire
découvrir le sport aux jeunes filles des
quartiers populaires
cette année les joueuses
professionnelles de calais faisait
office d'entraîneur anthony rech
le contrôle du ballon est encore parfois
hésitant et pour cause la plupart de ces
jeunes filles jouent pour la première
fois au basket c'était bien appris
comment aller jouer au basket et c'est
comme ça moi la prochaine fois si on
rentrait du basket à l'école ou autre
sera pas faire sur des ateliers de
passes de tir ou de dribbles ses jeunes
yvelinoise manie le ballon sur les
conseils des joueuses professionnelles
de calais actuellement en tête du
championnat de deuxième ligue féminine
elles sont venues partager leur passion
entre deux jours d'entraînement
c'est sûr que ça change de d'habitude
après c'est vrai que c'est toujours
sympa d'apprendre ce qu'est nous notre
métier à des jeunes mais pourquoi pas
des futurs basket hand on essaie surtout
qu'elle s'amuse c'est une journée où
elle s'amuse et si elle s'amuse
également aimé donc pour nous c'est tout
gagné
initié il ya neuf ans par la ligue
féminine de basket
l'opération marraine de coeur est un
projet unique en france qui n'existe
dans aucune autre discipline
l'objectif dans les yvelines faire
découvrir le basket à des jeunes filles
issus de quartiers sensibles qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de côtoyer les parquets
et les terrains de sport c'est un leur
faire découvrir le sport de les mettre
en relation par atelier avec
effectivement des exercices qui
permettent de comprendre ce qu'est le
basket il ya aussi dans ce cadre là un
atelier de discussion avec une joueuse
de haut niveau pour leur montrer un
petit peu qu'est ce que c'est que le
sport de haut niveau comme on peut y
parvenir le département des yvelines est
le premier de france en termes
d'évolution de licenciées féminines avec
12% d'augmentation 2013 et peut-être que
parmi les 180 jeunes filles présente ce
mercredi certaines fouleront les
parquets du département dans les
prochains mois
on continue sur le thème du sport et en
présente l'opération balle jaune qui
depuis 2008 permet de recycler les
balles de tennis usagées pour les
transformer en sols sportifs le point
sur cette édition 2014 toujours mené par
la fédération française de tennis
anthony rech et jonathan lynn maintenant
cinquante-huit mille c'est le nombre de
balles de tennis récolté cette année
grâce à l'opération balle jaune prise en
charge par la ligue des yvelines au lieu
de finir en jouets pour chiens une fois
récoltées ces balles de tennis usagées
prennent toute la direction d'une usine
de recyclage pour une seconde vie on va
en fait séparer la matière
caoutchouteuse de la feutrine et la
matière caoutchouteuse va devenir des
granulats en fait de caoutchouc qui vont
être mélangés à de la résine et qui vont
permettre la préparation d'un sol souple
pour des activités motrices pour des
personnes polyhandicapées ou des
déficients mentaux pour cette nouvelle
campagne de recyclage la majorité des
165 club lillois participent désormais à
l'opération devenu une habitude depuis
2011 pour preuve en l'espace de trois
ans la récolte est passé de 36 à 58000
balle nettement plus depuis quelques
années nous avons participé au recyclage
des balles dès que ça a été mis en place
par la ligue je crois que c'est en 2010
ou 2011
ça s'est fait petit à petit mais grâce
aux containers qui est très visuel les
balles sont très largement recyclé dans
notre club et pourtant
non nous beaucoup vingt-cinq mille
balles sont nécessaires pour réaliser un
seul 200 m² si l'opération de l'année
passée n'a pas connu de concrétisation
en 2014 plusieurs sites se sont déjà
portés candidats pour obtenir la
construction d'un terrain de sport
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi dans un instant le
7-8 week-end de yolaine thorez très
bonne fin de semaine sur tv fil 78